the Joe Rogan experience I never thought
about that make sense I love Texas yes
well party you live in I'm a New
Braunfels which is right outside of San
Antonio oh nice I've never been to San
Antonio it's nice man San Antonio is a
cool city we're actually right between
Austin and San Antonio oh that's great
oh it's perfect weather's like that
Riverwalk area supposed to be dope
that's cool I mean that's like the
tourist thing you know it's like it's
what they do it's like going to see the
Hollywood sign
like there's if you if you want to have
a good time just let me know when you
come in Texas and we'll go do some
redneck [ __ ] well my Brent my friend
John Dudley was just there with the
black rifle coffee guys yeah and they
went to some ranch that's just outside
of San Antonio that the [ __ ]
astronauts used to go to mmm he said to
these photos of Neil Armstrong with a
[ __ ] deer that is a uniquely American
place like when other I think when other
people think of America they really
think of Texas most people I mean I know
if they're thinking America they'll say
that it'll be Texas but if it's if it's
like Hollywood they'll say California
you know right those are the two let's
some people like every once in a while
think New York but I think what people
think about like crazy gun-toting
screaming at football you know
that's Texas yeah guarantee yeah 100%
dry rocks yeah it's a fun place yeah you
know a lot of fun lot less regulations a
lot more self self accountability yeah
well they have [ __ ] zebras and
giraffes and [ __ ] everywhere
they're loose yeah running around I work
with um with a but just became a
credited zoo that works a lot with
confiscated animals like they've got
hundreds of animals that basically some
redneck was like oh I'm gonna have a
white lion can't take care of it so they
take it these folks who were they got
high in this abandoned house and they
were in the house in Texas and there one
around this house smoking weed and they
walked into a room with a [ __ ] tiger
in a cage oh my god
they call the police
and they had the police come and rescue
this [ __ ] tiger but this was an
abandoned house oh [ __ ] oh my god yeah
there's a just I mean they weren't sure
like here you find it here oh you got
these goddamn pop-up ads to get in
craftier and crafts here with these
pop-ups and then you don't know if like
clicking exit it's gonna download
something sexist man look at this Texas
man enters abandoned home smoke weed
finds Tiger and starts - [ __ ] yeah he
said it was in a Reiki Day cage in the
homes garage but that's weird when you
treat animals like property you know
when you can just do whatever you want
with them and that's how Texas that's
how Texas views exotics anything that's
not like if you're if you have
white-tailed deer in Texas they have
pretty liberal tags like you can shoot a
good number of them but you have to get
tags right but if you have like a black
buck which is a African animal or a
nilgai or something like that you choose
many as you want right yeah they just
you do whatever you want you sell them
to your friends what does it say it was
secured only with a screwdriver and a
nylon strap I hope this guy got some
kind of [ __ ] punishment the guy who
owned the [ __ ] house yeah that's a
dick move man yeah that's a beautiful
tiger yeah the something really [ __ ]
up about seeing Tigers locked up I I
don't even like the fact that they feed
them I mean I feel like you just let
some loose in there yeah that's what I
was saying yeah that's what I was saying
but from what I was rolling yeah exactly
what I was told was that that was just
not PC like it wasn't acceptable I'm
sure do you ever see the footage of when
the US soldiers overtook Baghdad they
had they had zoos and Baghdad and what
they would do is that the Lions knew it
was happening so they would let these
goats out and these goats would be
wandering around and then they would
open the door and the Lions would sprint
because they knew exactly what this is
feeding time oh these goats had no idea
they let the goats out and the goats
like oh just hanging out being a goat
and then they would open up this [ __ ]
door and US soldiers filmed it and these
lions just make this [ __ ] mad
sprint to these goats and just malam and
that's how they ate uh-huh got posted
people shouldn't be pissed that's what
it is if you watch a [ __ ] you want
you go and see a parrot eatin seeds
that's what it eats right you know
may-maybe really identify with seeds and
you feel like it's brutal murder murder
of seeds yeah that lion wants to do that
that's what makes them a lion that makes
him happy and it's it's what they have
to do you know it's like there's a lot
more people getting published it's not
publicity but there's a lot more people
showing that side of things at least I
was we were talking about right before
we came on there's this Instagram page
called nature as metal taken down for a
while you know he got back up but he has
one of the very best pages how can you
take it down that's all he did he didn't
he had nothing to do with any of those
situations it's not like he like had
some kind of ulterior motive and came in
and put these animals in the situation
that's just reality
[Applause]